ja es ist wirklich dramatisch was da
alles gerade passiert rundum alexej
nawalny und diesen fall verfolgt
natürlich auch unser bild vize paul
ronzheimer sie sehen ihn schon er ist in
weißrussland in der hauptstadt in minsk
seit tagen
hier geht es ja gerade um den sturz von
diktator lukaschenko heftige proteste
seit zwei wochen
paul guten morgen an dich sag uns hat
alles das was in linz gerade passiert
mittlerweile nie zu tun wie schätzt du
dass ein oder ist das alles zufall
ich denke das wird wahrscheinlich nie
geklärt werden können ob es dort einen
zusammenhang gibt also es wird niemals
beweise geben
es gibt spekulationen darüber aber ich
hatte zumindest was den fakten angeht da
nichts für so plausibel dass man sagen
kann dass diesem zusammenhang
tatsächlich gibt sagte es aber natürlich
dass dadurch dass überall die weltweit
berichtet wird hier momentan der zirkus
ein wenig von den protesten von
lukaschenko weg gegangen jetzt auch wenn
man sagen muss runter zu insgesamt
weniger geworden sind aber zum fall eine
ich habe gerade eben die ersten
informationen bekommen von aktivisten
dass der zustand von navalny als er
gerade eben in berlin gelandet ist
stabil
also noch einmal das sind gute
nachrichten für all diejenigen die um
das leben von dabei die banken erste
informationen die wir hier exklusive
bilder alten haben das stand sonderbar
nach ankunft in berlin auch während des
fluges ist stabil
vielleicht noch einen hintergrund peter
afghanischen angesprochen es gab bei dem
flug zunächst die vermutung dass er in
schönefeld landen könnte das alles hat
mit den massiven sicherheitsmaßnahmen zu
tun die im fall einer weile getroffen
wurden nach unseren informationen ist
als bundeskriminalamt seit gestern
involviert hat sozusagen auch die
gesamte planung mit übernommen und
deswegen ist beim schweizer da wo
normalerweise klar zu erkennen ist
gelandet
auch angegeben worden dass dieses
flugzeug in schönefeld landen würde
als ablenkungsmanöver hier um zu davon
abzulenken und auch die presse davon
abzulenken dass er tatsächlich am
militärischen teil in tegel landet wie
bei bild wussten dass im vorfeld wir
wussten dass das flugzeug in tegel
landen würde und können deshalb exklusiv
berichten genau paul und wir sehen es
auch rechts von dir haben wir das
livebild die ganze zeit eingespielt
unsere zuschauer können die maschine
sehen sie steht auf dem feld wir sind
wirklich ganz ganz ganz nah dran wie du
es gerade auch sagt sag mal du bist ja
seit tagen in minsk und du hast auch mit
vielen leuten kontakt wie reagieren denn
die menschen in minsk das bürgerliche
volk wie wir reagieren sie auf diesen
fall die menschen in linz sind hier wie
man sagen muss auf der ganzen welt
geschockt davon dass es erneut so ein
fall in russland gibt es ist ja nicht
das erste mal dass in russland oder
außerhalb russlands ein gegner putins
vergiftet wurde
aber was die proteste in wien angeht da
haben die menschen natürlich die ganz
eigenen sorgen nämlich die sorge dass
dieser protest hier blutig wieder
zerschlagen werden könnte
da ist geschenkt wo die polizei und die
gefürchteten spezialkräfte und an diesem
wochenende einsetzen könnte gestern hat
es eine erste gestern hat es eine erste
einer abschiebung von journalisten
gegeben die bei einem prozess sozusagen
festgenommen wurden von radio liberty
also man versucht hier wieder art
durchzuschlagen aber natürlich die
menschen zittern mit mit jemandem wie
navalny wenngleich man sagen es gibt
hier in linz geben keine wirklich putin
scheint liche russlandfreundlichen
stimmung
das ist nur das was gerade transportiert
wird in den russischen staatsmedien
was nichts mit der realität zu tun hat
paul vielen dank für den moment unser
bild vize und wir wünschen dir einen
guten start in den tag pass auf dich auf